well the rocket brothers who
would later become quite important and
become big muckety-mucks in Hollywood
and 1923 no one had heard of them they'd
made their money in railroads and
smelting but they had a passion to tell
the story of Abraham Lincoln and they
approached Francis Marion because they'd
already been turned down by every studio
in town saying that you have any names
attached so they went to Francis and
said please because we know if you're
attached then we can get it made we can
get it released and Francis always was a
soft spot for the underdog but also she
really loved the idea of trying to
educate while entertaining and was
fascinated by the story and took it on
even not only to the point of not
getting paid but then putting in fifty
thousand dollars of our own money when
the production was stalled for lack of
funds and you know it's a key was an
incredibly huge production I mean was
over 60 featured players over a you know
100 sets I mean this was an epic on the
same scale as some birth of a nation and
and others similar I think this film is
just this trailer that we're going to
this extended trailer which is really
what we see here is just a reminder and
a little glimpse into what we have lost
this incredible story of me when you
read the reviews of this movie at the
time it said you know if education could
always be this entertaining we would
have the most educated population in the
world that the other things such as
raving about the humanizing of Lincoln
and making him a three-dimensional
person and that kind of thing we we
don't get we don't see that so this
trailer tonight shows us what we've lost
it's so where it's representative of the
what practically whether they say eighty
percent of all silent films that are
gone forever and I particularly always
irked by the euphemism that these are
lost films no they aren't lost they're
gone forever because people either sold
them for scrap needed room in the vault
or just put them on a shelf and let them
rot and I just hope that it's reminder
of the efforts that we need to put into
preservation today not only of the
things when we find them but of the
films that we made that were made in the
60s and 70s that are need to be
preserved now if they're going to last
for future generations
you